from the time that there is an awareness
of the existence of the soul will say
Circa 50 000 BP until the resolution of
the apocalyptic potential
there's something like 50 000 years
which in biological time is only a
moment but it is the entire span of
History times five
in that period everything hangs in the
balance because it is a mad rush from
monkey dumb to Starship hood and in the
leap
across those 25
000 years energies are released
religions are shot off like Sparks
philosophies evolve and die science
arises magic arises all of these things
which control Power with greater and
lesser degrees of ethical constancy
appear there is the possibility as in
the metaphor of dying there is the
possibility of mucking it up of aborting
the species transformation into a
hyperspatial intellecty we are now there
can be no doubt that we are now in the
final seconds of that crisis the crisis
which involves
the end of History the departure from
the planet the triumph over death and
the release of the individual from
matter we are in fact closing distance
with the most profound event to
planetary ecology can encounter which is
the freeing of life from the dark
Chrysalis of matter the old metaphor of
psyche as the butterfly is a
species-wide metaphor we must undergo a
metamorphosis in order to survive the
momentum of the historical forces
already in motion I want to tell you a
Campfire story about
a poor but humble primate
who came from
the fringes of the action a minor member
of the Flora and Fauna of this planet
who embarked on a long and arduous
journey into time and had Many
Adventures along the way
and had many allies along the way and
overcame great challenges to attain the
gift difficult to come upon the Grail if
you will or the self I mean all fans of
Joseph Campbell are familiar with this
metaphor of the hero's journey and
what's interesting is we actually have
made that hero's journey we are all of
us tonight Sons and Daughters of the
ancestral Heroes who overcame drought
glaciation disease famine earthquake
migration you name it they didn't drop
the ball and thanks to them we're here
tonight
and normally this is uh the beginnings
of this great journey are completely
cloaked in mystery it's taught in
Orthodox anthropology courses no one
knows the factors which impelled human
beings to leave the primate existence in
the canopies of the great forests of
Africa and to adopt uh new styles of
life in the grasslands new diets trading
in vegetarianism for being omnivores
trading in a life of fruititarian luxury
for
a life of hunting struggle migration and
natural selection in an extremely harsh
environment I believe that the reason
that this seems so mysterious to
straight
primatologists and anthropologists is
because they have been unwilling to look
carefully at the role that plants played
in this adventure particularly the role
that psychoactive plans may have played
and then most appropriately for this
gathering tonight the role that certain
species of psychoactive mushrooms
we now are the inheritors of a planet
which is dying under anesthesia our
entire cultural crisis is predicated on
the fact that we cannot feel or connect
with the consequences of our history
that we have behaved very badly we of
the high-tech societies we have trashed
gender relationships we have trashed
Aboriginal societies we have cut down
the rain for us we have robbed our own
children of a future as rich as the
future that we expect ourselves to enjoy
there isn't even a name for this sin
where you destroy the opportunity of
your own children I mean no Society has
been that perverse and we're doing it
under a massive infusion of alcohol all
laced with monotheistic moral propaganda
what is the antidote to this well it's
what I call the archaic revival it's
something that's been going on
throughout most of the 20th century but
with increasing depth and urgency it's
that we must reach back into the past to
the last sane moment that we ever knew
and figure out what was going on then
and get with the program and attempt to
recover some amount of cultural
equilibrium and balance and I believe
that you know using the broad brush of
generalization we could say all our
problems can be traced down to Ego
ego lies behind private property it lies
behind the domination of women by man it
lies behind dollar chasing it lies
behind all of the maladaptive behaviors
the arms race the whole thing it lies
that are pushing us toward planetary
toxification and species Armageddon
build communities of like-minded people
and diminish the almighty sense of ego
and psilocybin does this very
effectively in two ways first of all it
dissolves boundaries between people and
another way of saying ego is that I
strongly distinguish between you and me
you know that's what ego tells you is
who you are and how important you are
and how you're not her or him or that or
that you're this psilocyment tends to
dissolve that language reinforced
misperception and the other thing it
does is it shows you that behind your
eyebrows is a world richer by far than
any of the crap that's being peddled on
Rodeo Drive or Fifth Avenue in New York
City or anywhere else in other words
it shows you the pathetic nature of
materialism by reintroducing you to the
reality of the spirit not as a religious
abstraction that's used to beat you over
the head to follow somebody's moral
recipe but as a felt experience of the
indwelling of an extreme power that a
power that connects you to all the life
of the past on this planet to the
planetary future to the Universe At
Large so really it's a rediscovery of
our Birthright as human beings history
is a bad deal it's a it's a mass of
potage it's broken machines and Broken
Dreams because we have projected our
value system out into matter and matter
has not not responded in a satisfying
way and so we're then dysfunctionally
neurotic always seeking never finding
you see what the Psychedelic is going to
do is it's going to destroy your whole
world your whole conception of your
world and some people that's
tremendously liberating they say
wonderful at last I'm free of it other
people say my God now I'm in hopelessly
mad I have nothing left to cling to I've
really done it this time and and so that
that's almost an aesthetic judgment
whether you like watching your world
shredded before your eyes and made into
nonsense if that's makes you feel
liberated insecure then you can sign up
for this Carnival if that alarms you I
think best to stick to the tribe and
true it's not for people of weak psychic
Constitution and what Shamanism is about
is I mean I know someone who says of the
mushrooms my goal with taking mushrooms
is always to be able to stand more
and and they don't mean higher doses
they mean more of what it reveals and I
feel like that I mean the mushroom
speaks I didn't really stress this in my
talk but the strange the confounding
fact about these mushrooms is that they
speak to you in plain English and this
is uh completely
unexpected how can such a thing be I
mean one is dumbfounded in the presence
of this and and yet uh by being able to
have an eye thou relationship to this
thing you open up yourself to uh what is
essentially a magical Dimension a
dimension of allyship uh with this thing
I come to this completely as a
rationalist I mean I am a more scientist
more rationalist than anything else I am
very uncomfortable with my position in
the new age I hate all that stuff the
quartz crystal suppositories and the
channeling of dead Egyptians and all
this horrible stuff which goes on I mean
it's just an affront to the thinking
mind
but when I encountered these
psychedelics I said my God
skepticism is the proper path and and I
believe this it's and it's not to
believe it's to test I said to the
mushroom once Why Us meaning My Brother
and Me Why Us and it said because you
don't believe in anything you know
you're not a Believer and so it's it's a
real thing it's a real mystery it will
not yield to reason it's a tremendously
well-kept Secret
yes first come the dancing mice the
little candies the colored grids and so
forth and so on but what eventually
happens quickly like 10 minutes later is
uh there is an entity
in the trance in the vision there is a
mind there waiting that speaks good
English and invites you up into its room
and what it is is it's a voice in the
head that people strove to attain for a
thousand years this was the sine of
intellectual accomplishment in the
Greco-Roman world and the logos told you
the right way to live
and this is sort of what you get with
psilocybin you get a voice that can
confound you with the depth and
Brilliance of its answers this is what
you want and I've had over and over the
experience of showing somebody what five
grams is and they're appalled they say
my God you can't be serious I mean I
take a fifth that much a fourth that
much yeah well that's the problem that's
why you don't have elves in the attic
and bats in the Belfry like I do a lot
of people uh
have said you're a hallucination not
you're obsessed with hallucination I
freely admit it
uh but I will defend my obsession with
vision I think the world wants to be
seen I think Blake was right that the
Divine imagination is something beheld
and for me the Visions are the proof
that this is not my mind and the Visions
are the proof that this is not simply
chemical chaos in the nervous system and
when we communicate with each other and
understand each other we instinctively
reach for visual metaphors I see what
you mean look here fella uh she painted
a picture uh his words were so beautiful
it means that we really associate
meaning with seeing something
this is why the Psychedelic experience
and psychedelics are so important it's
because they are tools for understanding
and revisioning the reality in which we
all live the personal growth is a
wonderful thing and will naturally
follow along but it's more important
than that it's a way to make a new world
that is daoistic
feminine free of anxiety and in great
anticipation of further stages of
completion lying into the future that's
that's where the mystery the
transcendental object the pot of gold at
the end of the rainbow is waiting and I
think that's the job of each of us to
show our best toys and our best tricks
that lift us and our friends to higher
and higher levels and there is no end to
this bootstrapping process the the
future of the human mind and body and
the future of humans together is
endlessly bright
keep the faith recognize each other and
to
maybe I should close with a little line
from Gary Snyder if I can remember it he
said
learn the flowers
travel light
Stay Together
I am not a guru I have no particular
acts of my own to grind or at least not
with great vigor
I the point to be made here is that
psychedelics are not an ideology or a
position they are an experience and an
experience is something that we have
very intimately ourselves so it's not
something you can teach people or Draw
too many General conclusions from it's
an experience but it's an experience
that I feel uh people should have and
when I see a political system or a set
of cultural values that are denying
people this experience then I feel like
some kind of Human Rights abuse is
taking place the tension between uh
so-called straight culture and
psychedelic culture is attention over uh
values
psychedelics challenge
assumptions of any cultural or political
system and that makes them dangerous to
every cultural and political system so
if there's anything a Marxist
dictatorship a high-tech industrial
democracy or a theocracy they can all
get together on one thing which is
psychedelic drugs or a knife poised at
the heart of Community Values well this
is just simply nonsense and then all the
reasons brought forth are in a sense a
red herring the psychedelics are among
the safest substances known for human
ingestion considering the depth of their
impact on human mental functioning the
fact that you pick yourself up six seven
eight hours later and to go on about
your business with an expanded point of
view is quite remarkable people have a
right to get stoned they have a right to
think and explore their own minds this
is as intimate a part of their being as
their sexuality
and in any culture which mitigates that
is clearly afraid of a full and fair and
open dialogue about what reality is and
what real human values ought to be
now Dr Hoffman has been lauded here this
evening for his invention of LSD
certainly this is what he will be
remembered for over the long centuries
ahead but as a matter of fact he is a
thinker of extreme breaths and deaths it
was he working with Carl Ruck and Gordon
Wasson who proposed that it was actually
a psychoactive ergot alkaloids that lay
behind the illicinian Mysteries and
thereby rub the nose of classical
scholarship in the fact that the
foundation and the Wellspring of the
western imagination which was the
mystery Cults of ancient Greece that
that Foundation is firmly rooted in a
psychedelic experience that when we
leave these things behind we leave
behind our cultural Birthright no less
than when the Amazonian Indian desserts
his home Village for the Sawmills we too
were once tribal people who lived in the
light of mysteries that came to us
mediated by shamans and created out of
the magic of the natural world it was
Alfred Hoffman who synthesized
psilocybin for the first time and
described its absolute structural
characteristics this is a man who is
astride both the synthetic and natural
product chemistry of the 20th century
like no one else his research has
revealed the unexpected fact that there
are biodynamic alkaloids in our
environment in our food chain indeed in
our history that argue that we are the
bearers of a great promise that the
future of conscious business can be
endlessly bright
in the future it will be unimaginable
that governments once regulated the
substances that people use to explore
personal growth it is the mark of a
barbarous culture and we are here to
raise the light to say truth is not so
easily swept aside one doesn't just say
no to truth
true
truth requires engagement
it requires courage
it requires a sense of where we have
been and of where we are going
we expect to command our body we expect
the mental Will to order the monkey
flesh into action and it will follow the
body is the Nexus of the mystery of life
and our culture takes us out of the body
and cells our loyalty into Political
systems into religions into inanimate
objects and machines collections so
forth and so on the felt experience
of the body is what the psychedelics are
handing back to us that's why it's
called Escape because it's escape from
HBO from walking the mall from seeing
what's on the tube from consuming trash
media it's escape from all of that into
the authenticity of the body this is why
sexuality is so edgy in this Society
they'd make it illegal if they but could
figure out how it's it's the one drug
they can't tear from our grip and so
they lay a guilt trip about it but
sexuality and psychedelics by carrying
us back to an authentic sense of the
body carry us back to the domain of
authentic values and more and more the
message that people are getting as they
Avail themselves of the Psychedelic
experiences that it is not a journey
into the human unconscious or into the
ghost bar dose of our chaotic
civilization it's a journey into the
presence of the gaian mind that the
Earth is a coherent whole it is a
thinking feeling intending being that in
terms of our value structures it would
be foolish to image as anything other
than female
and when cultural values created by male
dominance and Science and linearity and
so forth and so on when those values are
dissolved what is waiting there is this
incredibly poignant experience of Matrix
what James Joyce called the mama Matrix
most mysterious nothing more than our
bodies and the Earth out of which our
bodies came history as we have lived it
in the west has been a turning of our
back on that and now history has failed
Western cultural institutions having
become Global cultural institutions now
show themselves to be adequate to
inspire lead or carry anyone into a
future worth living in at this moment
then this reconnecting to the guy in
mind becomes a kind of moral imperative
I will never forget my first DMT trip
because I was such a case going into it
I mean if you had known me when I was 19
years old I was into Jean-Paul sarte
Alfred Camille Marxism
Freud I was a jerk
and uh and I came down from it and I
said I can't believe it that was all I
could say for about 20 minutes I was
like in shock I said I can't believe it
I can't believe it Jesus I can't believe
it and I said you know I've got to go
back to square one all these people I
dismissed all these people who say the
universe is made of levels who say there
are disincarnate intelligences who say
that the you know death is not simply
the yawning grave I had dismissed all
those people as cry baby peace and SOB
sisters and I said no you know the point
of view that I previously dismissed is
apparently what's actually happening so
in a single experience I was converted
from naive
rationalism realism reductionism to my
present position whatever it is really
all I've done is worked out the
implications of the personal
implications for me of the DMT Flash and
I've also tried to create linguistic
models of it
um
so the worth of it is that it shows you
beyond a shadow of a doubt that the
world is made of magic that's what the
world is made of not natural law not
interlocking cause and effect not any of
these things that are normally the world
is Magic not a little bit 100 percent
every Atom from one end of this Cosmos
to the other is magic magic
certain concerns just die in the first
30 seconds of the DMT flashing can never
be brought back to my mind I felt in
danger of dying from astonishment when I
did it and I do every time I do it I
mean I I don't know how they keep the
lid on this stuff I mean I think that
this is the secret that wants to be told
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]